San Francisco de Quito, the capital of Ecuador,...
...sits at over 9,000 feet above sea level.
Quito's volcanic peaks straddle the equator,...
...the invisible line around the center of the Earth...
...after which this South American country was named.
Located high in the Andes, on the bulge of the equatorial line,...
...Quito is the closest national capital to the sun.
Fitting for a place at the intersection of two hemispheres,...
...there is symmetry everywhere you look.
As a meeting point between two equal halves,...
...Quito is all about balance.
Just like the Earth, it's intersected by an imaginary line,...
...separating the UNESCO-protected Old Town...
...from the trendy New Town, mirroring the past with the present.
To see both halves at once, take the gondola up the Pichincha Volcano.
On these slopes, a historic battle took place...
...that resulted in Quito's liberation from Spain in 1822.
Declaring victory was independence leader Antonio Jose de Sucre,...
...whose statue stands far below, in front of the Santo Domingo Church.